these days shows aren't exactly afraid
to kill off the main character or two
especially if it serves the story or the
show gets little extra social media
attention in the process here's a
spoiler filled look at some TV character
deaths on major shows in 2019 that were
unthinkable but still totally happened
Game of Thrones wrapped up a number of
character arcs in its eighth season the
way Game of Thrones likes to do with a
grizzly on-screen death the Battle of
Winterfell was an event that the series
has long been building up to and
promised an absolute resolution to one
of the show's biggest storylines after
all how could the show's various groups
and families vie for the Iron Throne if
they couldn't fight off the night king
in the massive undead army under his
control in the end the army of the
Living seemed helpless to stop at all
save for the lucky intervention of a
certain assassin what do you say to the
god of death
[Music]
and so the night Kings reign was brought
to a swift end by Arya Stark and her
Valyrian steel dagger instantly
destroying every last undead soldier in
the process while Gotham serves as a
prequel series to the well established
events of the Batman comics and movies
the show easily grew into its own over
the course of five seasons
it also deviated a fair bit from its
source material delivering the
occasional surprise plot twist that
didn't quite match up with what Batman
fans might have expected to happen a
year ago Tabitha felt the wrath of
Oswald Cobblepot also known as the
penguin in his convoluted revenge plot
over the death of his mother
butch once dead and resurrected as the
grotesque solomon grundy struck up a
tender relationship with Tabitha who is
otherwise known as tigress the penguin
killed butch right in front of Tabitha
adding injury to insult by shooting her
in the leg swearing to finish her off
someday she did manage to survive into
Gotham's final season but only to
fulfill Oswald's prophecy at the height
of 2019 snowman's land plot arc
Cobblepot finally stabs and kills poor
Tabitha based on Neil Gaiman's legendary
novel showtimes American Gods operates
on the conceit that all the gods anyone
has ever believed
are real in that they wander around the
u.s. in human form having been brought
to the new world hundreds of years prior
and while you might assume that gods are
pretty much unkillable American gods
doesn't agree the show had no qualms
then and bumping off NAB's sweeney an
ancient Irish King turned bird turned
six foot tall leprechaun in the
present-day this scrappy God worked as
muscle for mr. Wednesday leader of the
old gods early in the series however
Matt Sweeney's magical powers failed
when he lost his enchanted coin his luck
and good fortune having come to an end
Sweeney finds himself unable to
understand why his life is falling apart
driven to madness he turns on shadow
moon the show's lead only foreshadow to
stab him in the heart
beeps series finale sees lead character
Selina Meyer become president of the
United States after a series of
machinations and manipulations at her
party's national convention Selina gets
the nomination when she courts Jonah
Ryan support by making him her running
mate and gets buddy Calhoun on board by
agreeing to ban same-sex marriage
one final roadblock is swiftly overcome
after Mayer frames her loyal assistant
Gary for corruption and has him sent to
prison I coulda done it without you
worry I'm not going anywhere the episode
then flashes forward to Selena in the
Oval Office and then to more than 20
years later when Selena's press
secretary turned CBS News reporter Mike
McClintock covers the ex-presidents
funeral veep saves one last joke for its
put-upon protagonist when Mike
interrupts and then ends his coverage of
the presidential memorial to pursue the
breaking news that beloved actor Tom
Hanks has died it sometimes seemed like
the story of Game of Thrones was really
the story of Daenerys Targaryen mother
of dragons Khaleesi of the great grass
sea and heir to the Iron Throne
unfortunately Danny's story came to a
very final end in the show's last
episode worn down by her relentless
quest for power and the deaths of her
allies the show's final chapters saw her
succumb to madness and burned down
King's Landing with Dragon Fire this
decision which caused the deaths of
countless innocents also led to the loss
of support from her lover and nephew Jon
Snow as well as her chief adviser Tyrion
Lannister I freed my brother
and you slaughter this city after all
Daenerys went through in Game of Thrones
over the years it seems almost cruel
that she came so close to a happy ending
but any chance of that ended with her
descent into tyranny to prevent Daenerys
from inflicting her madness on the rest
of the world Jon Snow stabbed her to
death only feet from the throne she'd
always wanted Supergirl killing off Lex
Luthor is shocking largely because he's
by far the most famous rogue in the
Superman mythos and one of the most
notorious villains in superhero fiction
altogether with his death where does
Supergirl even go from there well in his
final moments of life
Lex revealed that Kara Danvers and
Supergirl are one in the same it was a
tantalizing cliffhanger as well as an
inglorious into a season-long arc for
the evil industrialists politician and
super villain after all all he ever
really wanted to do was defeat Superman
and kill Lois Lane and create an evil
Supergirl clone is that really so bad
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]